[Music]
on this wednesday night
amplifying demands for justice for
residential school survivors
i would call for an investigation of
crimes against humanity
the call for criminal investigations at
all former residential schools
kovid's rapid resurgence out west the
threat of a fourth wave and
one region's about-face on masks
the owner of the habs apologizes for
drafting an admitted sex offender
the new promises after penalties against
the team pile up
making canadian olympic history penny
alexia's new distinction
plus simone biles bows out there's a lot
of expectations and pressure
an olympic champions pivotal maneuver to
prioritize
mental health
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
[Music]
good evening and thanks for joining us
calls are growing for more criminal
investigations into allegations of abuse
at former residential schools in this
country sexual
physical and psychological abuse that
was widespread and went on
for decades the rcmp major crimes unit
is in the midst of a criminal
investigation into abuse
at the former fort alexander residential
school northeast of winnipeg
now a group representing chiefs from 34
manitoba first nations is asking for
similar investigations at all
residential schools
saying criminals must be brought to
justice
what i would like to see is for for the
rest of society
uh you know worldwide to understand
right what was being said was true right
and that's all
many of the victims already testified at
the truth and reconciliation commission
reliving their painful past but they are
still waiting for justice
brittany greenslade has our top story
tonight it's pain
and trauma from abuse decades ago but a
wound that's still fresh
for mary corchain when i was five years
old
that it changed that day
forever um
i was placed by force
to go to residential school
myself and my brother and it was like
that it was the law
of the land she spent the next decade at
the fort alexander residential school
northwest of winnipeg the 10 years that
i spent
in residential school was
the the most awful years of my life
awful because i was torn away from
my a loving home with a
siblings and a mom and dad that were
loving
and i we were happy while difficult
she speaks about her time so others know
what happened
and the abuse she says she and many
others suffered
we knew we whispered
and a lot of
children talked about it there was abuse
there was abuse and it was common
knowledge but
like i said our lift was healed
we couldn't talk about it the former
school on sagin first nation is at the
center of an rcmp investigation
which began in february 2010 after
decades of allegations of sexual abuse
against former staff no charges have
been laid
the truths have to be found you know
whatever the outcome is
you know let the process again run its
course and then you know whatever the
outcome is
you know and that's what we have to wait
for right is that outcome
but even to get to this point mounty
spoke to hundreds of people across north
america
and canvas door to door on the first
nation to track down 75 witnesses and
victims
that alone can have a lasting and
significant impact
on community members we're dealing with
the
with the search in the residential
school site
it's been pretty traumatic for the
community it's pain and trauma one
counselor says needs to be met
with added support there is this chance
to say
let's be there for each other and let's
come close let's take care of each other
let's be a community in this together so
that
nobody has to go through this alone
support
the sagine first nation needs going
forward brittany greenslade global news
winnipeg it's believed thousands of
staff members abused students at
residential schools over the many
decades they operated
many of those people are dead few have
been held to account
and as michael couture reports
accountability goes far beyond
just those individuals but i
carried that
that sexual abuse and assault for 49
years
for six years the truth and
reconciliation commission heard about
decades of abuse and suffering from
survivors of canada's residential school
system
news of manitoba rcmp launching a
criminal investigation at just one
former school
has some wondering if there will be
similar inquiries
at the 138 other schools and then on top
of that there were things called
day schools and also indian hospitals
cindy blackstock is the head of the
first nations child and family caring
society
she believes any investigation should go
much further
than just the criminal courts i would
call for an investigation out of crimes
against humanity
and i want to ensure that people
understand not only
individuals should be held accountable
but the institutions
in a statement justice minister david
lametty said the deputy attorney general
of canada must consent
to commence proceedings for crimes
against humanity
but he wouldn't say if that would be
happening
indigenous services minister mark miller
says our country
is facing a reckoning canada has to step
up we have said that we will in many
ways financial
mental health supports supporting in
investigations
and seeking the truth which as we know
is is so important and a precursor to
reconciliation
the trc revealed there were thousands of
cases of alleged abuse
but there have been fewer than 50
convictions
legal counsel for the native women's
association of canada believes
more charges should be laid but he
worries that might not happen
all sexual assault um cases they're
challenging because it really comes down
to
unfortunately to say this but the
credibility of the victim
and you know as time goes on there's
less you know
they remember less and it's more
difficult that's partly because of the
passage of time but
also because too many victims have
buried the pain
after years of suffering and anguish
mike lacrosse global news ottawa
there is some support for survivors a
24-hour crisis line is available for
anyone experiencing pain or distress
as a result of their or their family's
residential school experience
the number is toll-free you can speak in
confidence it's 1-866-925-4419
well as much as we'd like to see the end
of the pandemic the virus is
still with us and in some provinces a
fourth wave is looming
in alberta where about 25 percent of
eligible people haven't received a first
vaccine dose yet
the virus is again spreading fast the r
value that's the rate at which the virus
reproduces is now
at 1.48 that means 100 people who are
infected can spread it to
148 more a similar rise is happening in
the interior of bc
heather urex west explains why that is
ringing alarm bells
it's been almost a month since alberta's
open for summer plan
took effect the return of indoor dining
live
music even large-scale events like the
calgary stampede have been welcomed by
many
but covet 19 has taken advantage too
i think we are having a bit of a bump
right now and if if
the numbers continue to increase it'll
be migrated into a full wave
alberta isn't the only province seeing
cases increase
bc and alberta both relaxed most coveted
restrictions on july
first at the beginning of the month
daily case counts were less than 50.
now they have jumped to more than 130.
the calgary stampede which ran from july
9th to 18th
says 71 cases of covet have been linked
to the event
but there could still be more infections
that have just not yet been identified
well certainly you know our
our our value is running at about 1.5 so
when you see
70 cases at the stampede you're going to
see more cases
as a consequence of those cases on
average nbc
public health officials aren't taking
any chances effective midnight
thursday new coven 19 restrictions
including a mandatory mask mandate for
indoor public spaces will be in place
for the central okanagan
home to most of bc's current covet 19
spread
during the period of time for this
outbreak we are
discouraging any non-essential travel
into the central okanagan region for
those people who are
not fully immunized but in alberta covet
restrictions are easing
even more starting august 16th isolation
will no longer
be universally legally required if you
test positive for covid19
although it may be required in some
high-risk settings we need
to give these struggling employers
confidence that they can
hire people back and do it safely
and that's why our focus is on vaccines
instead of restrictions differing
strategies for a pandemic in its final
chapters
though still very much a threat heather
eurex west global news
calgary canada didn't make the uk's
green list for travel so fully
vaccinated canadians will still have to
quarantine when they arrive
even though fully vaccinated americans
and most europeans will be able to enter
england and scotland without
quarantining
they'll still need to take covet 19
tests pre and post arrival but they
won't need to isolate for 10 days
the new rules kick in on monday there is
one major exception
france has been deemed higher risk
because of the prevalence of the beta
variant in that country
no reason was given for excluding canada
from the relaxed rules despite canada
having a higher vaccination rate
than the u.s tokyo has set
a new alarming covet 19 record that city
is reporting
more than 3 100 new cases today a new
all-time daily high tokyo has been under
its fourth state of emergency since july
12
just ahead of the olympics the surge is
being driven by the more contagious
delta variant prime minister justin
trudeau made another campaign-style stop
today this time in newfoundland and
labrador
he announced a multi-billion dollar deal
with that province he says will keep
people's electricity bills from spiking
because of the muskrat falls
hydroelectric project the 5.2 billion
dollar agreement includes a one billion
dollar loan and a one billion dollar
investment in the infrastructure to
transport power from the generating
station in labrador
to the island and beyond the remaining
3.2 billion will be annual cash
transfers from the federal government's
net revenue from the hibernia offshore
oil project the muskrat falls original
price tag of 6 billion
has ballooned to an estimated 13 billion
and without
help from the fed's electricity
customers in newfoundland and labrador
would be on the hook to pay for it once
the project
is fully operational in the fall and
power begins to flow to the grid
thank god the federal government was
there to to step up and let us recognize
the problem
and help us navigate the solution we
know the future is going to require more
clean energy
and the pressures and the challenges
faced by newfoundlanders and
labradorians for mistakes made in the
past
is something that canadians all needed
to step up on
and that wasn't the only agreement
announced today newfoundland and
labradors also signed on to the national
child care program which aims to make
ten dollar a day daycare spots available
for children under the age of six it is
the fifth
jurisdiction to reach a deal for that
federal funding program
amia culpa from the owner of the
montreal canadiens coming up the apology
and the explanation for drafting an
admitted sex offender
the owner of the montreal canadiens is
trying to manage the damage done to the
team's reputation after drafting
18 year old logan mayu meu was convicted
and fined in sweden where he played
hockey
after admitting to sharing an explicit
photo of a woman without her consent
the canadians knew about that when they
picked him in the draft
what they didn't expect it seems was any
backlash
mike armstrong reports hey you right
point winds up takes the shot towards
that and he scores
even before ever putting on a canadian's
jersey
logan mayu may be one of the most
controversial players in team history
have's owner jeff molson in a written
statement admits
picking mayor quote turned out to be
instantaneously
very offensive to many he says fans
expect more from us
and we let you down i apologize for the
pain
this selection caused logan may you
the canadians selected mayor in friday's
draft even after the player himself
asked teams not to pick him this year he
put out a statement earlier in the week
saying being drafted was a privilege one
he hadn't shown the maturity to earn
well molson says the team picked mayu
because it made sense in
hockey terms he's a strong player they
thought they were giving him a second
chance but didn't properly assess
the impact well that impact was a hit to
the brand
major sponsors came out to say they were
reviewing their association with the
team
uncomfortable with the pick in the
statement molson thanks
everyone that provided their feedback on
the situation
including our partners and sponsors so
that this mistake becomes an opportunity
to grow
and raise awareness to do that molson
says the team will create a plan to
educate other young men and women about
the dangers of taking
and sharing intimate images i think that
the canadians
need to own it moshi landers and
economics professor
concordia university he says the
canadians can undo
some of the damage from this disastrous
week but it's going to take
time it may involve mayu speaking out
even visiting
schools and universities what you do now
is the montreal canadiens those you say
look we we did make a mistake but the
way that we're going to put it right is
not by getting rid of the kid
we're going to address the problem may
you the canadians are promising to get
the player
counseling but apparently not a jersey
for now mayu's been told he won't be
participating in the rookie camp
or the main training camp this fall mike
armstrong global news
montreal
still ahead the growing sense of urgency
in canada for action on climate change
there is no ignoring the extreme weather
events that are happening
more often now and with greater
intensity wildfires are destroying whole
communities
torrential rain is causing deadly
flooding it's what climate scientists
warned us
would happen and a poll down for global
news found there's a growing consensus
among canadians that climate change
needs to be urgently addressed as eric
sorenson explains each new disaster is
adding more fuel to the calls
for action it's been an unprecedented
year of extreme weather
and however you felt in the past a
majority of canadians 57
say recent events like heat waves and
wildfires in the west
have changed their opinion on the
urgency to fight climate change
of that majority an ipsos survey done
for global news last week found a much
bigger number 49
said yes they feel more urgent compared
with 8 percent who feel less urgent
about climate change than in the past
regionally residents in bc and quebec
are feeling the greatest urgency
above 50 percent though other provinces
are above 40.
far fewer canadians feel less urgency
alberta the one province where those who
feel that way
is in double figures what we're seeing
is canadians
um kind of seen for the first time
really the direct impacts of climate
change
i think it's not surprising that it
started to change
people's opinions about the urgency of
doing something about this crisis
the survey found of those who lean
toward the conservative party about 30
percent feel more urgent about climate
than before
while supporters of the other four
parties all register above
60 percent greater urgency and
young canadians who will endure the
effects of climate change for decades to
come
are seized of the issue for younger
people that climate change has become
one of those
existential issues of our age and and
there's a unanimity among younger people
as to
the importance of the issue and the need
to do something about it the survey did
find about half of canadians unwilling
to spend more
including taxation to fight climate
change but the costs are already rising
and will only grow the per capita costs
for individuals in canada
due to weather disasters have already
increased from something like six
dollars per year prior to 2010
to 40 50 a year after 2010 but the
reality is that they're very real costs
to not acting on climate
an increasing number of corporate
investors are beginning to shift away
from fossil fuels
but climate advocates say it really is
government that has to drive the policy
transformation
needed to address climate change eric
sorensen global news toronto
mental health takes the podium next one
athlete elevating the conversation
at the olympics
and historic homecoming for canada's
softball team they've returned from
tokyo after winning canada's first
olympic medal in that sport
the bronze medal is especially sweet for
star pitcher sarah gronawagen
back in 2018 she was put into a
medically induced coma after contracting
legionnaire's disease and she fully
recovered
canada's penny olexiac swam her way into
the history books she won bronze in the
women's 200-meter freestyle race
and she is now canada's most decorated
summer olympian
the toronto born 21 year old has
collected six olympic medals
four at the rio games in 2016 and two in
tokyo
she could still win more she's set to
compete in four
other events one american athlete is
making news for
not competing simone biles a superstar
gymnast
withdrew from two events saying she
needs to focus on her mental well-being
other elite athletes who know the
pressure to perform have applauded her
courage
competitive sports is about both mind
and body
and as crystal gomencing reports biles
has elevated the conversation
about mental health
simone biles executed the biggest and
possibly most difficult move of her
career
the 24 year old superstar hit pause
four-time olympic gold medalist biles
withdrew from the women's gymnastics
team event then announced she would not
take part in the all-round final in
tokyo
her american teammates are standing by
her saying they wouldn't be at the
olympics in the position they're in
without her dedication and skill
canadian gymnast ellie black
appreciates the pressure to perform like
simone says it's
sometimes you feel like you have the
weight of the world on your shoulders
and
there's a lot of expectations and
pressure the 25 year old from halifax
will also
not compete in the all-round competition
after spraining her
ankle she choked back tears saying she
hopes to regain her strength
and be able to compete at the beam event
next week
it's difficult it's frustrating it's
upsetting
it you know the culture has often been
you go to you drop
angela schneider knows the pressure of
competing first hand as a silver medal
rower
she's currently researching pandemic
related effects on athletes their
training
and mental health the world is now
becoming a little more accommodating
in understanding mental health issues
and anxiety
and treating them and i think that it's
time now in sport
for people to recognize this viles
withdrew after tennis star naomi osaka
the world's
highest paid female athlete lost her
match on tuesday
ending her olympic run she said the
pressure she was under
was intense osaka withdrew from the
french open
in may to take a mental health break and
was ridiculed online
biles is also experiencing some of that
on social media proving
there's still more work to be done on
mental health acceptance
crystal gomencing global news london
and that is global national for this
wednesday i'm donna friesen
tonight's your canada is the village of
badeck prince edward island we'd love to
see your canada
please email it to viewers at
globalnational.com
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow take care of yourselves
[Music]
bye-bye
you